the following is a conversation with Lee
Smolin he's a theoretical physicist
co-inventor of loop quantum gravity and
a contributor of many interesting ideas
to cosmology quantum field theory the
foundations of quantum mechanics
theoretical biology and the philosophy
of science he's the author of several
books including one that critiques the
state of physics and string theory
called the trouble with physics and his
latest book Einsteins unfinished
revolution the search for what lies
beyond the quantum he's an outspoken
personality in the public debates on the
nature of our universe among the top
minds in the theoretical physics
community this community has its
respected academics it's naked Emperor's
its outcasts in his revolutionaries its
Mad Men and his dreamers this is why
it's an exciting world to explore it's a
long-form conversation I recommend you
listen back to the episodes with Leonard
Susskind Sean Carroll Michio Kaku max
tegmark Eric Weinstein and Jim Gates you
might be asking why talk to physicist if
you're interested in AI to me creating
artificial intelligence systems requires
more than Python and deep learning it
requires that we return to exploring the
fundamental nature of the universe and
the human mind theoretical physicists
venture out into the dark mysterious
psychologically challenging place of
first principles more than almost any
other discipline this is the artificial
intelligence podcast if you enjoy it
subscribe on YouTube get five stars an
Apple podcast supported on patreon or
simply connect with me on Twitter Alex
Friedman spelled Fri D M am as usual
I'll do one or two minutes of ads now
and never any ads in the middle that can
break the flow of the conversation I
hope that works for you and doesn't hurt
the listening experience this show is
presented by cash app the number-one
finance app in the App Store when you
get it you scolex podcast
cash app lets you send money to friends
buy Bitcoin and invest in the stock
market with as little as $1 since cash
app allows you to buy Bitcoin let me
mention that
the currency in the context of the
history of money is fascinating I
recommend a cent of money as a great
book on this history debits and credits
on Ledger's started around 30,000 years
ago the US dollar of course created over
two hundred years ago and Bitcoin the
first decentralized cryptocurrency was
released just over ten years ago so
given that history cryptocurrencies
still very much in its early days of
development but it still is aiming to
and just might redefine the nature of
money if you get cash app from the App
Store or Google Play and use the code
Lex podcast you'll get ten dollars in
cash app will also donate ten dollars
the first one of my favorite
organizations that's helping to advance
robotics and STEM education for young
people around the world and now here's
my conversation with Lee Smolin what is
real let's start with an easy question
put another way how do we know what is
real and what is merely a creation of
our human perception and imagination we
don't know you don't know this is
science I presume were talking about
science and we believe or I believe that
there is a world that is independent of
my existence in my experience about it
my knowledge of it and this I call the
real world so he said science but even
bigger than science what sure sure I
need not have said this is science I
just was you know warming up warming up
okay now that we're warmed up let's take
a brief step outside of science is it
completely a crazy idea to you that
everything that exists is merely
creation of our mind so like there's a
few not many this is outside of science
now people who believe sort of
perception is fundamentally what's in
our human perception the visual cortex
and so on the the cognitive constructs
that's being formed there is the reality
and then anything outside is something
that we can never really grasp that's
the crazy idea too
there's a version of that that is not
crazy at all what we experienced is
constructed by our brains and by our
brains in an active mode so we don't see
the raw world we see a very processed
world we feel something was very
processed through our brains and our
brains are incredible but I still
believe that behind that experience that
mirror fail or whatever you want to call
it there is a real world and I'm curious
about it can we truly how do we get a
sense of that real world is it through
the tools of physics from theory to the
experiments or can we actually grasp it
in in some intuitive way that's more
connected to our ape ancestors or is it
still fundamentally the tools of math
and physics that really allow us to grow
so let's talk about what tools they are
what you say are the tools of math and
physics I mean I think we're in the same
position as our ancestors in the caves
or before the caves or whatever we find
ourselves in this world and we're
curious we also it's important to be
able to explain what happens when there
are fires when they're not fighters what
animals and plants are good to eat and
all that stuff and but we're also just
curious we look up in the sky and we see
the Sun and the moon and the stars and
we see some of those move in we're good
we're very curious about that I think
we're just naturally curious so we make
up this is my version of what I were we
make up stories and explanations and
where there are two things which I think
are just true of being human we make
judgments fast because we have to we're
to survive we is that a tiger is that
not a tiger
and we go act we have to act fast on
incomplete information so we we judge
quickly and we're off and wrong but at
least sometimes wrong which is all I
need for this we're off in Iran so we
fool ourselves and we fool other people
readily and so there's lots of stories
that get told and some of them result in
a concrete benefit and some of them
don't and so he said we're often wrong
but what does it mean to be right right
that's that's the that's a that's an
excellent question to be right
well since I'm I believe that there is a
real world I believe that to be you can
challenge me on this if you're not a
realistic realistic somebody who
believes in these this real objective
world which is independent of our
perception if I'm a realist
I think that to be right is to come
closer I think first of all this a
relative scale is not right and wrong
this writer more right than less right
and you're more right if you come closer
to an exact true description of that
real world now can we know that for sure
now in the scientific method is
ultimately what allows us to get a sense
of how close were getting to that real
world no one to counts first of all I
don't believe his scientific method ha I
was very influenced when I was in
graduate school by the writings of Paul
fire Robin who was enough an important
philosopher of science who argue that
there is no scientific method there is
or there is not there's not can you
elaborate if sorry if you were going to
but can you elaborate on the what does
it mean for there not to be a scientific
method this notion that I think a lot of
people believe in in this day and age
sure Paul Farben or he was a student of
popper who taught opera Karl Popper and
Farben argued both by logic and by
historical exam
well that you named anything that should
be part of the practice of science say
you should always make sure that your
theories agree with all the data that's
always meant it's already been taken and
he'll prove to you that there have to be
times when science contradicts when some
scientist contradicts that advice for
science to progress overall so it's not
a simple matter I think that
of science as a community and a people
of people and as a community of people
bound by certain ethical precepts
precepts whatever that so in that
community a set of ideas they operate
under I'm meaning ethically of kind of
the rules of the game they operate under
don't lie report all your results
whether they agree or don't agree with
your hypothesis check the training of a
scientist mostly consists of methods of
checking because again we make lots of
mistakes we're very error-prone
but there are tools both on the
mathematics and the experimental side to
check and double-check and triple-check
and a scientist goes through a training
and I think this is part of it you can't
just walk off the street and say yo I'm
a scientist you have to go through the
training and the training the test that
lets you be done with the training is
can you form a convincing case for
something that your colleagues will not
be able to shout down because the last
did you check this and did you check
that and did you check this and what
about seeming contradiction with this
and you've got to have answers to all
those things or you don't get taken
seriously and when you get to the point
where you can produce that kind of
defense and argument then they give you
a PhD that's and you're kind of licensed
you're still going to be questioned and
you still may propose or publish
mistakes but the community is gonna have
to waste less time fixing your mistakes
yes but if you can maybe linger on it a
little longer what's the gap between the
thing that that community does and the
ideal of the scientific method was the
scientific method is you should be able
to repeat an experiment
there's a lot of elements to what
construes the the scientific method but
the final result the hope of it is that
you should be able to say with some
confidence that a particular thing is
close to the truth right but there's not
a simple relationship between experiment
and hypothesis or theory for example
Galileo did this experiment of dropping
a ball from the top of a tower and it
falls right at the base of the tower and
an Aristotelian would say Wow
of course it falls right to the base of
the tower that shows that the earth
isn't moving while the ball is falling
and Galileo says no wait there's a
principle of inertia and has an inertia
in the direction with the earth isn't
moving and the tower and the ball in the
or thought moves together when the
principle of inertia tells you at his at
the bottom it does look like therefore
my principle of inertia is right you
know Stettin Ian says no peristyle
science is right the earth is stationary
and so you gotta get an interconnected
bunch of cases and work hard to line up
and isolated centuries to make the
transition from Aristotelian physics to
the new physics it wasn't done till
Newton in 1687 in 1687 so what do you
think is the nature of the process that
seems to lead to progress if we at least
look at the long arc of science of all
the community of scientists they seem to
do a better job of coming up with ideas
that engineers can then take on and
build rockets with or build computers
with or build cool stuff with I don't
know a better job than what
then this previous century so century by
century we can talk about we'll talk
about string theory and so on and kind
of possible well you might think of as
dead ends and and so on not do it we
will string whistles straight
but there's never less than science very
often at least temporary dead ends but
if you if you look sure at the through
centuries
you know the century before Newton in
the century after Newton it seems like a
lot of ideas came closer to the truth
that then could be usable by our
civilization to build the iPhone right
to build cool things that improve our
quality of life that's the progress I'm
kind of referring to let me can I say
that more precisely yes I think it's a
it's important to get the time places
right yes there was a scientific
revolution that partly succeeded between
about 1900 or late 1890s and into the 22
1930s 1940s and so and maybe some if she
stretched it into the 1970s and the
technology this was the discovery of
relativity and that included a lot of
developments of electromagnetism the
conformation which wasn't really well
confirmed into the 20th century that
matter was made of atoms and the whole
picture of nuclei with electrons going
around this is early 20th century and
then quantum mechanics was from 1905 it
took a long time to develop to the late
1920s and then it was basically in final
form and the basis of this partial
revolution we can come back to why it's
only a partial revolution is the basis
of the technologies you mentioned all of
I mean electrical technology was being
developed slowly with this and in fact
there's a close relation between
development of electric electricity and
the electrification of cities in the
United States and Europe and so forth
and the development of the science the
size of the fundamental physics since
the early 1970s doesn't have a story
like that and so far there's not a
series of triumphs and progresses and
there's not a there's not any practical
application so just to linger briefly on
the early 20th century and the
revolutions in science that happened
there what was the method by which the
scientific community kept each other in
check about when you get something right
when you get something wrong is
experimental validation ultimately the
final test it's absolutely necessary and
the key things were all validated two
key predictions of quantum mechanics and
of the theory of electricity and
magnetism so before we talk about
Einstein now your new book before string
theory quantum mechanics on let's take a
step back at a higher level question
what is that you mentioned what is
realism
what is anti realism and maybe why do
you find realism as you mentioned so
compelling realism is you is the belief
in the in an external world independent
of our existence our perception our
belief our knowledge a realist as a
physicist is somebody who believes that
there should be possible some completely
objective description of each and every
process at the fundamental level which
which describes and explains exactly
what happens and why it happened
that kind of implies that that system in
a realist view is deterministic meaning
there's no fuzzy magic going on that you
can never get to the bottom you can get
to the bottom of anything and perfectly
describe it some people would say that
I'm not interested in determinism but I
I could live with the fundamental world
which which had some chance in it so
deep he said you could live with it but
do you think God plays dice in our
universe I think it's probably much
worse than that
in which direction I think that theories
can change and theories unchanged
without warning I think the future is
open
you mean the fundamental laws of physics
can change you okay we'll get there I
thought I thought we would be able to
find some solid ground but apparently
for the ground is the entirety of it
temporarily so probably okay let's uh
so realism is the idea that while the
ground is solid you can describe it
what's the role of the human being
our beautiful complex human mind in the
in realism do we have them are we just
another set of molecules connected
together in a clever way or the observer
this is the observer our human mind
consciousness have a role in this
realism view of the physical universe
there's two ways there's two questions
you can be asking it does our conscious
mind you are perceptions play a role in
making things become in making things
real or if things becoming that's
question one question two is does this
we can call it a naturalist view of the
world that is based on realism allow a
place to understand the existence of and
the nature of perceptions and
consciousness in mind and that's
question two
question two I do think a lot about and
my answer which is nine answers I hope
so but it certainly doesn't yet so what
question one I don't think so but of
course the answer to question one
depends on question two right so I'm not
up to question one yeah the question two
is the thing that you can kind of
struggle with at this time as what about
the anti-realists so what flavour what
are the different camps of anti-realist
that you've talked about I think it'd be
nice if you can articulate for the
people for whom there is not a very
concrete real world as there's divisions
or there's a it's Messier then the
realist view of the universe what are
the different camps for the different
views I'm I'm not sure I'm a I'm a good
scholar and can talk about the different
camps and analyze it but some many of
the inventors of quantum physics were
not realness weren't I realist in their
scholarship they lived in a very
perilous time between the two world wars
and there were a lot of trends in
culture which were going that way but in
any case they said things like the
purpose of science is not to give an
objective realist description of
nature's it would be in our absence this
movie might be saying Niels Bohr
the purpose of science is as an
extension of our conversations with each
other to describe our interactions with
nature and we're free to invent and use
terms like particle or wave or a
causality or a time or space if they're
useful to us and they carry some
intuitive implication but we shouldn't
believe that they actually have to do
with what nature would be like in our
absence which we have nothing to say
about do you find any aspect of that
because you kind of said that we human
beings tell stories defined aspects of
that kind of entire realist view of
Niels Bohr
compelling that were fundamentally are
storytellers and then we create tools of
space and time and causality and
whatever this fun quantum mechanic stuff
is to help us tell the story of our
world sure I just would like to believe
that is an aspiration for the other
thing driving being what the the realist
point of view do you hope that the
stories will eventually lead us to
discovering discovering the real world
as it is yeah it's perfection possible
by the way though
oh well that's you mean will we ever get
there and know that we're there yeah
exactly that's not mine that's for
people 5,000 years in the future we're
certainly nowhere near there yeah do you
think reality that exists our sight
outside of our mind do you think there's
a limit to our cognitive abilities is
again descendants of apes for just
biological systems is there a limit to
our minds capability to actually
understand reality sort of there comes a
point even with the help of the tools of
physics that we just cannot grasp some
fundamental aspects of that again I
think that's a question for 5,000 years
in the future element I think there is a
universality here I don't agree with
David Deutsch about everything but I
admire the way he put things in his last
book and he talked about the role of
explanation and he talked about the
universality of certain languages of the
universality of mathematics or of
computing and so forth and he believed
that universality which is something
real which is it somehow comes out of
the fact that the symbolic system in a
mathematical system can refer to itself
and in every I forget what that's called
in reference
back to itself and build in which he
argued for a universality of possibility
for our understanding whatever is out
there but I'm I admire that argument but
I it seems to me we're doing okay so far
but we'll have to see whether there is a
limit or not for now we got we got
plenty to play with yeah there are
things which are right there in front of
us which we miss and I'll quote my
friend Eric Weinstein in saying look
Einstein carried his luggage Freud
carried his luggage Marx carried his
luggage Martha Graham carried her
luggage etcetera Edison carried his
luggage all these geniuses carry their
luggage and not once before relatively
recently did it occur to anybody to put
a wheel on luggage and pull it and it
was right there waiting to be invented
for centuries so this is Erik Y Stein
yeah what do the wheels represent are
you basically saying that there's stuff
right in front of our eyes that once we
it just clicks we put the wheels in the
luggage a lot of things will fall into
place yes that I do I do and every day I
wake up and think why can't I be that
guy who was walking through the airport
what do you think it takes to be that
guy
because link you said a lot of really
smart people carried their luggage
mm-hmm what just psychologically
speaking so Erik wants that is a good
example of a person who thinks outside
the box yes who resists almost
conventional thinking you're an example
of a person who by habit by psychology
by upbringing I don't know but resists
conventional thinking as well just by
Nature that's that's a compliment
good so what do you think it takes to do
that is that something you were just
born with I doubt it well from my
studying some cases because I'm curious
about that obviously and just in a more
concrete way when I start out in physics
because I started a long way from
physics so it took me a long not a long
time but a lot of work to get to study
it and get into so I did wonder about
that and so I read the biographies and
in fact I started with the autobiography
of Einstein and Newton in Galileo and
all those all those people and I think
there's a couple of things some of it is
luck being in the right place the right
time
some of it is stubbornness and arrogance
which can easily go wrong
yes and I know I know all of these are
doorways if you go through them slightly
at the wrong speed or any wrong angle
they're their ways to fail but if you
somehow have the right look the right
confidence and arrogance caring
I think Einstein cared to understand
nature with ferocity and commitment that
exceeded other people of his time so he
asked more stubborn questions he asked
deeper questions I think and there's a
level of ability and whether ability is
born in or can be developed at a sensor
which can be developed like any of these
things like musical talent dimension ego
what's the role of ego in that process
confidence confidence but you do in your
own life if you found yourself walking
that nice edge of too much or too little
so being overconfident and therefore
leading yourself astray or not
sufficiently confident to throw away the
conventional thinking of whatever the
theory of the day of theoretical physics
I don't know if I I mean I've
contributed where I've contributed
whether if I had had more
confidence in some things I would have
gotten further I don't know whether
certainly hi I'm sitting here at this
moment with very much my own approach to
telling everything
and I'm calm I'm happy about that but on
the other hand I know people whose
self-confidence vastly exceeds mine and
sometimes I think it's justified and
sometimes I think it's not justified
your most recent book titled Einstein's
unfinished revolution so I have to ask
what is Einsteins unfinished revolution
and also how do we finish it well that's
something I've been trying to do my
whole life but Einsteins unfinished
revolution is the twin revolutions which
invented relativity theory special and
especially general relativity and
quantum theory which he was the first
person to realize in 1905 there would
have to be a radically different theory
which somehow realized to resolve the
paradox of the duality of particle wave
for photons and he was I mean people I
think don't always associate I style
with quantum mechanics because I think
his connection with it
founding as a one of the founders I
would say of quantum mechanics he kind
of put it in the closet is it well he
didn't believe that the quantum
mechanics as it was developed in the
late 19th middle late 1920s was
completely correct at first he didn't
believe it at all
then he was convinced that it's
consistent but incomplete and that also
is my view it needs for various reasons
I can elucidate to have additional
degrees of freedom particles forces
something to reach the stage where it
gives a complete description of each
phenomena and as I was saying realism
demands so what aspect of quantum
mechanics
bothers you and Einstein the most is it
some aspect of the wavefunction collapse
discussions the measurement problem is
it the the the measurement problem I'm
not gonna speak for Einstein but the
measurement problem basically and the
fact that what is the measurement
problem sorry the basic formulation of
quantum mechanics gives you two ways to
evolve situations in time one of them is
explicitly when no observer is observing
or no measurement is taking place and
the other is when a measurement or
observation is taking place and they can
treat they basically contradict each
other but there's another reason why the
revolution wasn't completed which is we
don't understand the relationship
between these two parts general
relativity which became our best theory
of space and time and gravitation and
cosmology and quantum theory so for the
most part general relativity describes
big things
quantum theory describes little things
and that's the revolution that we found
really powerful tools to describe big
things and little things and it's
unfinished because you wouldn't have two
totally separate things and we need to
figure out how to connect them so it can
describe everything right and we either
do that if we believe quantum mechanics
as understood now is correct by bringing
general relativity or some extension or
general relativity that describes
gravity and so forth into the quantum
domain that's called quantize the theory
of gravity or if you believe with
Einstein that quantum mechanics needs to
be completed and this is my view then
part of the job of finding the right
completion or extension of quantum
mechanics would be one that incorporated
space-time in gravity so where do we
begin so first let me ask perhaps you
can give me a chance if I could ask you
some just really basic questions well
there
at all the basic questions and the
hardest but you mentioned space-time
what is space-time space-time you talked
about a construction so I believe the
space-time is a intellectual
construction that we make of the events
in the universe I believe the events are
real and the relationships between the
events which cause which are real but
the idea that here is a four-dimensional
smooth geometry which has a metric in
the connection and satisfies the
equations that Einstein wrote it's a
good description to some scale it's a
good approximation it captures some of
what's really going on in nature but I
don't believe it for a minute is
fundamental so okay let's we're gonna
allow me to linger on that so the
universe has events events cause other
events there's this idea of causality
okay so that that's happy let's in my in
your view Israel or hypothesis so the
theories that I have been working to
develop make that assumption
so space-time you said four dimensional
space is kind of the location of things
and time is whatever the heck time is
and you're saying that space-time is
both space and time are emergent and not
fundamental no sorry
before you correct me what is mean to be
fundamental or emergent fundamental
means it's part of the description as
far down as you go we have real yes as
real as real it could be yeah so I think
the time is fundamental and quote goes
all the way down and space does not and
the combination of them we use in
general relativity that we call
space-time also it is not but what is
time then I think that time the activity
of time is the continual creation of
events from existing event so if there's
no events
there's nothing then there's not only
not no time there's no nothing so so I
believe that history universe has a
history which goes to the past I believe
that a future does not exist there's a
notion of a present and a notion of the
past and the past consists of is a story
about events that took place to our past
she said the future doesn't exist yes
could you say that again can you try to
give me a chance to understand that one
more time so what the events caused
other events
what is this universe because we'll talk
about locality in nonlocality
good because it's the crazy I mean it's
not crazy it's a beautiful set of ideas
that you you propose but and if because
all these fundamental I just like to
understand it better
what is him what is the past what is the
future what is the flow of time even the
era of time in our universe in your view
and maybe it was an event right Oh an
event is where something changes or
where to I it's hard to say because it's
a primitive concept in the event is a
moment of time within space this is the
the view and general relativity where
two particles intersect in their paths
or something changes in the path of the
particle now we are postulating the
theories I have two fundamental level a
notion which is an elementary notion so
it doesn't have a definition in terms of
other things but it is something
elementary happening and it's it doesn't
have a connection to energy or matter or
exchange of any ties to have the
connection energies at that level
yeah it involves and that's why the
version of a theory of
that I've developed with Marina Cortez
and they say by the way I want to
mention my collaborators because they've
been at least as important in this work
as I have marina Cortes in all the works
since about 2013 2012-2013 about
causality Carlos set and in the period
before that Roberto mangabeira Unger who
is a philosopher and a professor of law
and that's in your efforts
together with your collaborators to
finish the unfinished revolution so yeah
and focus on causality and focus on
mental yes as fundamental to physics so
and there's certainly other people we've
worked with but those two people's
thinking had a huge influence on my own
thinking so in the way you describe
causality that's what you mean
of time being fundamental that causality
is from the yes and what does it mean
for space to not be fundamental to be
though that's very good this is a level
of description in which there events
there are events create other events but
there's no space
they don't live in space they have an
order in which they caused each other
and that is part of the nature of time
for us so but but there is an emergent
approximate description and you asked me
to find a version I didn't an emergent
property is a property that arises at
some level of complexity larger than and
more complex than the fundamental level
which requires some property to describe
it which is not directly explicable or
drivable is the word I want from the
properties of the fundamental things and
space is one of those things in a
sufficiently complex universe space
three-dimensional position of things
emerged yes and we have this we saw how
this happened
in detail in some models both
computationally and analytically ok so
connected to space is the idea of
locality yes that so we talked about
realism so I I live in this world at
like sports
you know locality is a thing that you
know you can affect things close to you
and don't have an effect on things that
are far away mm-hmm it's the thing that
bothers me about gravity in general or
action in a distance the same thing that
probably bothered Newton or at least he
said a little bit about it okay so what
do you think about localities it's just
a construct is it us humans just like
this idea and are connected to it
because we exist in it we need it for
our survival but it's not fundamental I
mean it seems crazy for it not to be a
fundamental aspect of our reality it
does and you comfort me and a sort of as
a therapist like how do i I'm not a good
therapist okay there are several
different definitions of locality when
you come to talk about locality in
physics in quantum field theory which is
a mixture of special relativity and
quantum mechanics there is a precise
definition of locality operative field
operators corresponding to events in
space-time which are space like
separated can meet with each other as
operators so in the in quantum mechanics
you think about the nature realities
fields and things that are close and if
you have an impact on each other more
than farther away that's yes that's very
comforting that makes sense so that's a
property of quantum field theory and
it's well tested unfortunately there is
another definition of local which was
expressed by Einstein and expressed more
precisely by John Bell which has been
tested experimentally and found
fail and this setup is you take two
particles so one thing that's really
weird about quantum mechanics is a
property called entanglement you can
have two particles interact and then
share a property without it being a
property of either one of the two
particles and if you take such a system
and then you magically make a
measurement on particle a which is over
here on my right side and particle B
which is over here and what somebody
else makes a measurement in a particle B
you can ask that whatever is the real
reality of particle B it not be affected
by the choice the observer at particle a
makes about what to measure not the
outcome just the choice of the different
things they might measure and that's a
notion of locality because it assumes
that these things are very far space
like separated and it's going to take a
while for any information about the
choice made by the people here at a to
affect the reality of B but you make
that assumption that's called bell
locality and you derive a certain
inequality that some correlation
functions of correlations have to
satisfy and then you can test that
pretty directly in experiments which
create pairs of photons or other
particles and it's wrong by many sigma
in experiment in is a match so what what
does that mean that means that that
definition of locality I stated is false
the the one that Einstein was playing
with and the one the one that I stated
that is it's not true that whatever is
real about particle B is unaffected by
the choice that the observer makes as to
what to measure in particle a no matter
how long they've been propagating and
almost the speed of light or the speed
of light away from each other it's no
matter so like the distance between them
well it's been tested of course if you
want to have hope for quantum mechanics
P
in completely wrong and corrected by
something that changes this it's been
tested over a number of kilometers I
don't remember whether it's 25
kilometers or 170 kilometers but so in
trying to solve the unsolved revolution
in trying to come up with a theory for
everything is causality fundamental and
breaking away from locality absolutely
fun a crucial step so the in your book
essentially those are the two things we
really need to think about as a
community especially the physics
community has to think about this okay I
guess my question is how do we solve how
do we finish the unfinished revolution
well that's I can only tell you what I'm
trying to do and what I have abandoned
yes it's not working as one ant smart
ant in an ant colony yep or maybe dumb
that's why he knows but anyway that's
become my view of the we've had some
nice theories invented there's a bunch
of different ones both related to
quantum mechanics related to quantum
gravity there's a lot to admire in many
of these different approaches but to my
understanding they none of them
completely solve the problems that I
care about and so we're in a situation
which is either terrifying for students
or full of opportunity for the right
student in which we've got more than a
dozen attempts and I never thought I
don't think anybody anticipated would
work out this way which work partly and
then at some point they have an issue
that nobody can figure out how to go
around or how to solve and that's the
situation we're in my reaction to that
is twofold one of them is to try to
bring him we evolved into this
unfortunate sociological situation in
which there are communities around some
of these approaches and to borrow again
a metaphor from Eric they sit on top of
hills in the landscape of theories and
throw rocks in each other and as eric
says we need two things we need people
to get off their hills and come down
into valleys and party and talk and
become friendly and it's learning to say
not know but but yes and yes your idea
goes this far but maybe if we put it
together with my idea we could go
further yes so in that spirit of talked
several times with Sean Carroll who's
also written an excellent book recently
and he kind of he plays around is a big
fan of the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics so I'm a troublemaker
so let me ask well what's your sense of
Sean and the idea of many-worlds
interpretation
I've read many the commentary back and
forth you guys you guys are friendly
respect each other but have a lot of fun
debating I love Sean and he know I
really he's not he's articulate and he's
a great representative or an ambassador
of science to the public in four
different fields of science to each
other he also like I do takes philosophy
seriously and
unlike what I do in all cases he has
really done the homework he's read a lot
he knows the people he talks to them he
exposes his arguments to the to them and
I did this mysterious thing that we so
often end up on the opposite sides of
with these issues it's fun though it's
fun and I'd love to have a conversation
about that but I would want to include
him
I see about many worlds well no I can
tell you what I think about many I'd
love to but actually on that let me
pause Sean as a podcast you should
definitely figure out how to talk to
Sean I would I actually told Sean I
would love to hear you guys just going
back and forth so I hope you can make
that happen eventually you and sure I
want I won't tell you what it is but
there's something that Sean said to me
in June of 2016 that changed my whole
approach to a problem but I have to tell
him first yes and that that's they'll be
great to tell him on his podcast so I
can't invite myself to his podcast yeah
okay we'll make it happen
so so many worlds anyway um what's your
view many worlds we talk about
nonlocality many worlds is also a very
uncomfortable idea or beautiful
depending on your perspective it's it's
very nice in terms of I mean there's a
realist aspect to it I think you called
it magical realism yeah it's just a
beautiful line but at the same time it's
very difficult to far eliminate human
minds to comprehend so what it what are
your thoughts about it let me start with
the easy and obvious and then go to the
scientific okay it doesn't appeal to me
it doesn't answer the questions that I
want answered and it does so to such a
strong case that when Roberto mangabeira
Unger and I began looking for principles
and I want to come back and talk about
the use of principles in science cuz
that's the other thing I was gonna say
and I don't want to lose that
when we started looking for principles
we made our first principle there is
just one world that happens once but so
it's it's not helpful to my personal
approach to my personal agenda but of
course I'm part of a community and my
sense of the many-worlds interpretation
I have thought a lot about it and
struggled a lot with it is the following
first of all there's Everett himself
there's what's in Everett and there are
several issues they're connected with
the derivation of the born rule which is
the rule that gives probabilities to
events and the reasons why there is a
problem with probability is that I
mentioned the two ways that physical
systems can evolve the many-worlds
interpretation cuts off one the one
having to do with measurement and just
has the other one the Schrodinger
evolution which is smooth evolution of
the quantum state but the notion of
probability is only in the second rule
which we've thrown away so where there's
probably come from and you have to
answer the question because
experimentalist use probabilities to
check the theory now at first sight you
get very confused because there seems to
be a real problem because in the
many-worlds interpretation the this talk
about branches is not quite precise but
I'll use it there is a branch in which
everything that might happen does happen
with probability one in that branch you
might think you could count the number
of branches in which things do and don't
happen and get numbers that you can
define as something like frequentist
probabilities and Everett did have an
argument in that direction but the
argument gets very subtle when there are
an infinite number of
abilities as is the case in most quantum
systems and my understanding although
I'm not as much of an expert as some
other people is that Everett's
own proposal it's failed did not work
there then it doesn't stop there there
is an important idea that Everett didn't
know about which is decoherence and it
is a phenomenon that might be very much
relevant and so a number of people post
Everett have tried to make versions of
what you might call many worlds quantum
mechanics and this is a big area and
it's subtle and it's not the kind of
thing that I do well so I consulted
that's why there's two chapters on this
in the book I wrote chapter 10 which is
about Everett's version in Chapter 11
there is a very good group of
philosophers of physics in Oxford Simon
Saunders David Wallace Harvey Brown and
a number of others and of course is
David Deutsch who is there and those
people have developed and put a lot of
work into a very sophisticated set of
ideas designed to come back and answer
that question they have the flavor of
there are really no probabilities we
admit that but imagine if you if the
Everett story was true and you were
living in that multiverse how would you
make bets and so they they use decision
theory from the theory of probability in
gambling and so forth to shape a story
of how you would bet if you were inside
average in the universe and you knew
that and there is a debate among those
experts as to whether they or somebody
else has really succeeded and when I
checked in as I was finishing the book
with some of those people like Simon
who's a good friend of mine
and David Wallace they told me that they
weren't sure that any of them was yet
correct so that's why I put in my book
now to add to that sean has his own
approach to that problem in what's
called self referencing or self locating
observers and it doesn't
I just tried to read it and it didn't
make sense to me but I didn't study it
hard I didn't communicate with Sean I
didn't do the things that I would do so
I had nothing to say about in the book
and I don't I don't know whether it's
right or not let's talk a little bit
about science you mentioned these
principles in science what does it mean
to have a principle and why is that
important when I feel very frustrated
about quantum gravity I like to go back
and read history and of course Einstein
and his achievements are a huge lesson
and hopefully something like a role
model and it's very clear the Einstein
thought that the first job when you want
to enter a new domain of theoretical
physics is to discover and invent
principles and then make models of how
those principles might be applied in
some experimental situation which is
where the mathematics comes in so for
Einstein
there was no unified space in time
Minkowski invented this idea of
space-time Fry's time it was a model of
his principles or his past humans and
I've taken the view that we don't know
the principles of quantum gravity I can
think about candidates and I have some
papers where I discuss different
candidates and I'm happy to discuss them
but my belief now is that those
partially successful approaches are all
models which might describe indeed some
quantum gravity physics in some domain
and
aspect but ultimately could would be
important because they model the
principles and the first job is to tie
down those principles so that's the
approach that I'm taking so the so
speaking of principles in your 2006 book
the trouble with physics you criticized
a bit string theory for taking us away
from the rigors of the scientific method
or whatever you would call it but what's
the trouble with physics today and how
do we fix it can I say how I read that
book sure because I and I'm not this of
course has to be my fault because you
can't as an author to claim after all
the work he put in this you were misread
but I will I will say that many of the
reviewers who were not personally
involved in even many who were working
on string theory or some other approach
to quantum gravity told me communicate
with me and told me they thought that I
was fair and balanced was though was the
way that was usually is so let me tell
you what my purpose was in writing that
book which clearly got diverted by
because there was already a rather hard
argument going on and this is on which
topic on string theory specifically or
in general and physics know more
specifically than string theory so since
we're in Cambridge can I say that we're
doing this yeah Cambridge just to be
clear Massachusetts and on Harvard
campus right so Angie's rominger is a
good friend of mine and has been for
many many years and Andy so originally
there was this beautiful idea that there
were five string theories and maybe they
would be unified into one and we would
discover a way to break that symmetries
of one of those string theories
and discover the standard model and
predict all the properties of standard
model particles like their masses and
charges and so forth coupling constants
and then there was a bunch of solutions
to string theory found which led each of
them to a different version of particle
physics with a different phenomenology
these are called the khalaby Yau
manifolds named after Yahoo is also here
not certainly we've been friends at some
time in the past anyway and then there
were nobody was sure but hundreds of
thousands of different versions of
string theory and then Andy found there
was a way to put a certain kind of
mathematical curvature called torsion
into the solutions and he wrote a paper
of string theory with torsion in which
he discovered there was and not formally
uncountable but he was unable to invent
any way to count the number of solutions
are classified the diverse solutions and
he wrote that this is worrying because
doing phenomenology the old-fashioned
way by solving the theory is not going
to work because there's going to be
loads of solutions for everything
proposed phenomenology for anything the
experiments just go now it hasn't quite
worked out that way but nonetheless he
took that worry to me he did he we spoke
at least once maybe two or three times
about that and I got seriously worried
about that and this is just a little
it's almost like an anecdote that
inspired you're worried about string
theory in general well I tried to solve
the problem and I tried to solve the
problem I was reading at that time a lot
of biology a lot of evolutionary theory
like lynn margulis and Steve Gould and
so forth and I all right I could take
your time to go through things that
occurred to me maybe physics was like
evolutionary biology
and maybe the laws evolved and there was
the Baris talked about a landscape a
fitness landscape of DNA sequences or
protein synthesis sequences or a species
or something like that
I took their concept and the word
landscape from theoretical biology and
made a scenario about how the universe
as a whole could evolve to discover the
parameters of the standard model and I'm
happy to discuss that's called
cosmological natural selection
cosmological natural selection yeah so
so the parameters of the standard model
so it says the laws of physics are
changing it this this idea would say
that the laws of physics are changing in
some way that echoes that of natural
selection or just it adjusts in some way
towards some goal yes and I published
that I wrote the paper in 1880 or 1890
paper was published in 92 when I first
book in 1997 the life of the cosmos was
explicitly about that and I was very
clear that what was important is that
because you would develop an ensemble of
universes but they were related by
descent through natural selection almost
every universe would share the property
that it was its fitness was maximized to
some extent were these close to maximum
and I could deduce predictions that
could be tested from that and and I
worked all of that out and I compared it
to the anthropic principle where you
weren't able to make tests or make
falsifications all of this was in the
late eighties and early nineties that's
a really compelling notion but how does
that help you arrive I'm coming to
whatever where the book came from yes so
what we've got me I worked on string
theory I also
Don Luhan gravity and I was one of the
inventors of the quantum gravity and
because of my strong belief in some
other principles which led to this
notion of wanting a quantum theory of
gravity to be what we call relational or
background independent I tried very hard
to make string theory backward
independent and ended up developing a
bunch of tools which then could apply
directly to general relativity and that
became a loop quantum gravity so the
things were very closely related and
have always been right closely related
in my mind the idea that there were two
communities one devoted to strings and
one devoted to loops is nuts and this
always been nuts okay so so anyway
there's this nuts community of loops and
strings that are all beautiful and
compelling and mathematically speaking
and what's the trouble with all that why
is that why is there such a problem so
what so I was interested in developing
that notion of how science works based
on a community and ethics that I told
you about
and I wrote a draft of a book about that
which had several chapters on
methodology of science and it was rather
academically oriented a book in those
chapters were the first part of the book
the first third of it and you even find
their remnants in what's now the last
chapter last part of the trouble with
physics and then I described a number of
test cases case studies and one of them
which I knew was the search for quantum
gravity and string theory and so forth
and I was unable to get that book
published so somebody made the
suggestion of flipping it around and
starting with a story of string theory
which was already controversial this was
2004-2005 but I was very careful to be
detailed to criticize papers and not
people you don't you won't find me
criticizing individuals you'll find me
criticizing
certain writing but in any case here's
what I regret let me make a program with
y-yes I as far as I know with the
exception of not understanding how large
the applications to condensed matter say
of a DMCA a DSC of T would get I think
largely my diagnosis of string theory as
it was then has stood up since 2006 what
I regret is that the same critique I was
using string theory as an example and
the same critique applies to many other
communities in science and all including
and this is where I regret my own
community that is a community of people
working on quantum gravity outside
string theory but and I considered
saying that explicitly but I say that
explicitly since I'm it's a small
intimate community I would be telling
stories and naming names of and making a
kind of history that I have no right to
write so I stayed away from that but was
misunderstood but if I may ask is there
a hopeful message for theoretical
physics that we can take from that book
sort of that looks at the community not
just your your own work on now with
causality and non locality but just
broadly in understanding the fundamental
nature of our reality what's your hope
for the 21st century in physics well do
we solve the problem it would solve the
unfinished problem of my science this is
that's certainly the the thing that I
care about most in hopefully let me say
one thing among the young people that I
work with I hear very often and since a
total disinterest in these arguments
that we other scientists have and an
interest in what each other is doing and
this is starting to appear in
conferences where the young people
interested in quantum gravity make a
conference may invite loops and strings
and causal dynamical triangulations and
causal set people and we're having a
conference like this next week a small
workshop at perimeter and I guess I'm
advertising this and then in the summer
we're having a big full-on conference
which is just quantum gravity it's not
strings it's not loops but the
organizers and the speakers will be from
all the different communities yes and
this to me is very helpful that the
different ideas are coming together at
least people are expressing an interest
in that there's a huge honor talking to
you Lee thanks so much for your time
today thank you thanks for listening to
this conversation and thank you to our
presenting sponsored cash app download
it used coal export cast you'll get ten
dollars and ten dollars will go to first
an organization that inspires and
educates young minds to become science
and technology innovators of tomorrow if
you enjoy this podcast subscribe on
YouTube give it five stars an apple
podcast follow on Spotify supported on
patreon or simply connect with me on
Twitter and lex friedman and now let me
leave you with some words from lee
smolin
one possibility is god is nothing but
the power of the universe to organize
itself
listening I hope to see you next time
you